large areas of Southern California are
under a state of emergency because of
raging wildfires the biggest of three
major fires is in Ventura County it's
burned an area nearly twice the size of
San Francisco more than 140 thousand
people in the region have been forced to
evacuate the fires have destroyed about
200 homes and other structures the three
fires are burning north and west of Los
Angeles the two largest are zero percent
contained david beg no is on the fire
lines and Ventura David good morning
good morning firefighters got a bit of a
break overnight as the winds died down
but the fire continued to move what it
did was it started to move down the
mountain sides in areas here in Ventura
County and actually jump over roadways
freeways snarling traffic more than
60,000 acres has burned so far roughly
20 miles
the winds are now starting to pick up
believe it or not it's actually chilly
in this area as the fire continues to
burn you can see those flames getting so
close to that house right there the
Thomas fire in Ventura County burned
through buildings overnight after a day
where wind driven flames turned hundreds
of buildings into ash
the winds made the battle from the air
difficult putting extra reliance on
ground crews a total of eleven hundred
firefighters are on the frontlines low
water pressure the result of high demand
has caused some hydrants to periodically
run dry
Dylan Chappell returned to what's left
of his home I mean obviously I'm
emotional but I'm just kind of like wow
it's all surreal at the moment around
6:30 Tuesday night the wind started to
die down but the fire continued to burn
we ran up on this fire that was burning
at a local business and even though the
winds have died take a look at the fire
alongside that mountain burning slowly
and relentlessly the fire has left
almost 50,000 customers without power in
Southern California
Cindy Harbor stood and watched the
hillside burned behind her home as she
got ready to evacuate how long have you
lived here 40 years five generations in
this house meanwhile in Los Angeles
County the so-called Creek Fire has
burned more than 11,000 acres destroying
more than 30 structures we're seeing
these poor horses that need to get out
of here
a local CBS News crew in Los Angeles
helped with horse evacuations as flames
overtook a ranch in the area all right
this is the start of a multiple day
weather event so we're not through this
yet the next 24 to 48 hours are going to
be some of the most challenging the
winds are expected to pick back up
schools around here have canceled
classes nearly every school in Ventura
County has closed air quality warnings
have been issued and Norah the smoke is
so thick around here that driving has
become extremely hazardous worried about
those people there David thank you